-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well,
and now we are gonna
get to the news.
President Biden today spoke with
allies and partners
about the situation in Ukraine.
Next he'll speak with
Republicans.
[ Laughter ]
After the U.S. offered
over the weekend to evacuate
Ukrainian President Volodymyr
Zelenskyy -- excuse me --
amid the Russian invasion,
Zelenskyy reportedly said,
"The fight is here.
I need ammunition, not a ride."
Oh, man, how badly does Biden
wish that quote was his?
[ Laughter ]
It's like Zelenskyy said, "Come
with me if you want to live."
[ Laughter ]
If Zelenskyy gets to fight
on top of a train,
he's officially living
Biden's best life.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm the Amtrak guy!"
During his keynote speech
on Saturday at CPAC,
former President Trump said that
the country has
"lost its self-confidence
under President Biden."
Well, of course.
We all had more self-confidence
under you.
Do you know how affirming it is
to be smarter
than the president?
[ Laughter ]
Waking up every day with a jump
in my step.
[ Laughter ]
In his soon-to-be-released book,
former President Trump's
attorney general William Barr
said, "Trump cared only about
one thing -- himself.
Country and principle
took second place."
I don't know, dude. Second?
[ Laughter ]
I think country took fifth place
and principle broke its leg
and had to be shot.
[ Laughter ]
"We can't save principle."
In the same book, Barr
criticized Trump and said,
"People are worthwhile to Trump
only as a means
to his ends as utensils."
Said Trump, "That's a lie.
I've never used a utensil
in my life."
[ Laughter ]
Ahead of tomorrow's
State of the Union address,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
is lifting the chamber's
mask mandate, which is
concerning to many House members
who still need them
for attention.
[ Laughter ]
A Ukrainian brewery
has reportedly switched
from producing craft beers to
making Molotov cocktails
to help fight
the Russian military.
Though, if you really want to
slow down the Russians,
just give them the craft beer.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, I felt like I ate
a loaf of bread."
[ Laughter ]
"Pumpernickel?"
Lawmakers in Florida last week
passed the so-called
"don't say gay" bill, which
prohibits classroom discussions
about sexual orientation
or gender identity.
Pretty soon,
a Florida school day
is just going to be seven hours
of quiet time.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Nothing more ironic than
when the "quiet time" punch line
gets the quietest response.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe they were honoring it.
New York Mayor Eric Adams
announced yesterday that
beginning next week,
the city will no longer
require vaccine passports
at restaurants,
which is great news for all the
restaurants who already stopped
checking them three weeks ago.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a dog house
that was struck by a meteorite
sold last week for $44,000.
Even crazier, it sold on Zillow.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.